hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the fido-flex s innovative
benchtop flow cytometry for research
applications I'm Robert
Castellanos of laberd's and I'll be a
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented my lab roots and
sponsored by Beckman Coulter F Beckman
Coulter we are dedicated to advancing
and optimizing the laboratory for more
than 80 years we have been a trusted
partner for laboratory professionals
helping to advance scientific research
and patient care we have a vital role
our focus on innovation reliability and
efficiency has led us to become the
partner of choice for clinical research
and industrial custom customers around
the globe for more information please
visit Beckman comm we have a few
important announcements before we began
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window who are
trying to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge a slide window by
clicking on the screen icon and the
lower right-hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window and submit your problem through
the creme Q&A button lower left I'd like
to introduce today's speakers a la dog
leash and azam gar here a la holds a BSc
and the pharmaceutical scientists
throughout his career he has worked with
seven blue chip pharmaceutical and
medical devices manufacturers a la
aspires to elevate the health care
provisions and life science research
standards across the Middle East Turkey
Africa and is highly interested in
understanding customers and stakeholders
specific operational needs
hence tailoring customers focused
solutions and process currently he
manages the Middle East and across the
life science companies and Anna Hanna
Azzam earns his MSC and bioscience
technology from the University of York
he worked as a field application
specialist responsible for collagen
products with a local distributor and
United Arab Emirates he then joined
Eppendorf as a product specialist for
the Middle East and Africa currently he
works with Beckman Coulter to support
work flow cytometry in the Middle East
North Africa and the Pakistan region I
will now turn it over to Allah for his
short presentation really introduces
back and cultural life sciences which is
part of it than in her life science
group of companies thank you for the
nice introduction I'd like also to thank
you all for joining our webinar today
this is actually among a series of
webinars for the life science group at
Danaher at Danaher customers talk we
listen quality is our focus so that we
innovate products to you at a
cost-effective parameter we work
together as teams to develop solutions
that answers the questions that you
raised to us Danaher specifically for
the Middle East we have a team of
application as well as technical support
specialists who are based across the
region mainly in Dubai as well as in
Saudi the life science operating
companies in Danaher are mainly for
companies like our micro systems which
serves different sectors sykes molecular
devices and Beckman Coulter for the
purpose of our presentation today we are
going to be focusing on battement life
sciences which actually has more than
two thousand associates employed across
the world mainly in 49 offices
and we serve customers in academia
Pharma and biotech research as well as
in hospitals I would like to thank you
again for joining my presentation and I
would like to have the presentation
again to the moderator thank you very
much Allah I will now turn it over to us
on for his presentation thank you Robert
good morning and good afternoon everyone
I am excited to talk today about the
site of flex s flow cytometer 'z which
are an extension of the innovative site
of flex platform from Beckman Coulter
life sciences so let's begin the
original site of flex system features a
compact footprint integrated detection
optics and lasers and a simplified but
highly reliable fluidic system it is
available in 21 standard configurations
with up to three lasers and 13 floors
and detectors to provide the great
application flexibility the site flex s
expands your research possibilities with
a food laser option it continues to
deliver superior performance with the
ease of installation and operation for
research application the site of flex is
known for
about the configurations available with
the Saito flex s so the side reflects s
system is available in preset
configurations with up to four lasers
from a choice of five while the site of
flags can be head with blue 488 red 638
and while it 4 or 5 nanometer lasers the
Saito flex s adds the option of yellow
green 561 nanometer laser and the near
UV 375 nanometer laser so these lasers
are specially separated and powerful to
give you an idea the violet laser
available on the side flex and side flex
s is 80 millivolt the nail UV laser
comes at 16 milli watt while the
standard blue and red lasers are 50
milli watt and the yellow green laser is
30 milli watt when you have the blue
laser you have the option of exciting
common dyes like FITC PE or FICO
aerotrain ECD from Beckman Coulter pc
5.5 or Percy P and P c7 with the red
lasers you have the option of exciting
APC APC alexa fluor 700 and a pc alexa
fluor 750 the wild it laser offers you
up to 5 channels in which you can have
specific blue chrome orange from Beckman
Coulter and the brilliant wallet 6 of 5
650 dies tandem dies the yellow green
laser gives you the option of exciting
PE and PE tandems along with fluorescent
protein
so the fighter flag systems will easily
fit on the bench or in the bio hood the
side-effects weighs about 24 kilograms
without the plate loader less than 50
pounds and it can be easily relocated by
the technology the single tube loader of
the sight of flags and side effects as
supports the standard 5 ml flow
cytometry tubes which are 12 by 75
millimeter in dimensions but you can
also use 1.5 and 2 ml micro centrifuge
tubes also available is an optional
96-well plate loader that can be ordered
as factory installed or as in upgrade
for site of flags in the field adding
the plate loader does not change the
dimensions of the side flex and the
operator has the choice of switching
between the plate loader or the single
tube loader modes in less than 5 minutes
so the plate loader accepts your
standard you bottom V bottom and flat
bottom 96-well plates the advantage of
plate loader is of course that you have
you can use less sample volume you have
options for mixing and these plates can
be ordered from Beckman culture or the
generic options available from other
vendors
in this slide we talk about the
performance the secret behind the site
of flex high performance is to
innovative wavelength division
multiplexing technology or WDM that we
use with avalanche photodiodes how does
this work fluorescence and scatter light
signals are directed to the WDM module
wire optical fibers the light is then
passed through a series of optics and
shrimpers which direct and focus
specific wavelengths onto an avalanche
photodiodes detector this Avalanche
photo bad detector replaces the PMT's
used in conventional flow cytometer x'
APD's have higher quantum efficiency
compared to PMT's and they have better
efficient performance in the far red
light spectrum for a pc dies if you spec
the side effects with the violet laser
you also have the option of having side
scatter collected from violet laser
elimination 405 nanometer laser light
causes greater side scatter signals than
488 nanometer laser light so when you
use a valid side scatter it is a great
feature
perfect for looking at exosomes and
micro particles - as small as 200
nanometer in size
in this slide we showed the use of
Sphero tech 8 pique beefs on a standard
side of flag system with blue red and
violet lasers what I would like to
highlight is that conventionally flow
cytometer struggle when it comes to
resolving the dim particles or the dim
beads in the far right channels of PC
seven and a PC this is no longer an
issue with the sight of Flex which
utilizes the WDM technology with
Avalanche photodiodes
you can see clearly that the rainbow
beads are well resolved and you can see
all the eight peaks in the PC 7 and ABC
channel when it comes to standard
channels for fitc and B you can see that
the sensitivity of the side of Flex is
class-leading
now let's talk about the utility
provided by the 561 nanometer yellow
later the 561 nanometer yellow laser is
perfect for exciting fluorescent
proteins like GFP D s red D tomato and M
cherry as you can see a comparison
between a standard blue laser sight
affleck system versus Society flex s
equipped with the 561 nanometer laser
when using 6:00 p.m. cherry beads you
can see that you can resolve all the six
Peaks using the yellow green laser
when using bacteria labeled with am
cherry the signal-to-noise ratio or the
separation between the positive and
negative peak using the 561 nanometer
laser is much superior to blue laser
light elimination now
let's talk about the near UV 375
nanometer lasered option available on
the side flex path using the near UV
laser allows you to excite brilliant
ultraviolet reagents without incurring
the cost of a true UV laser in this
example you can see whole blood stained
with Daffy and CD 3 the CD 3 is labeled
with brilliant violet 737 and hoods dye
you can use the brilliant violet 737
with 780 band pass filter or 7 1 2
nanometer bandpass filter you would want
to avoid using 7 1 2 nanometer bandpass
filter if we are going to use dyes like
alexa fluor 700 on red laser line
let's go to another slide here we are
looking at a 12 color experiment which
includes brilliant of ultraviolet dyes
and standardized use on the blue and
violet laser lines this is an immuno
phenotyping application where we are
looking at cd14 positive monocytes
lymphocytes with sig labeled with P D 3
which are T lymphocytes 356 and 16
labeled natural killer cells and the
separation between cd4 and cd8 t-cells
if you look at the performance of CD 3
which is labeled with brilliant
ultraviolet dye you can see that the
resolution between the positive and
negative population is clear to see
in this slide we are looking at cell
viability using Hertz and Debbie daddy
can be excited by the wallet or the near
UV laser and you can see the results are
comparable with Hertz which is excited
by the near UV laser so again you can
use the near UV laser with eighty
millivolts our on the side of flex s
instead of using a much more expensive
and heat-generating ultraviolet laser so
that top I talked about the hardware
specifications and features let's come
back to the software available with the
site reflects the side effects and side
effects s no matter the version comes
with site expert software site expert
software is easy to learn easy to use
and easy to maintain
it supports compensation using cells or
beads it supports quality control using
situ flex daily quality control beads
and we also provide training for the
site expert on our website free of
charge this is a fully featured software
which has acquisition and analysis modes
if you're familiar with the diva
software the site expert software is
easy to pick up and use
so we provide complete instrument
quality control using the Saito flex
daily QC beads the target channel
settings are provided on the web which
are imported into the site expert
software which automatically does QC
checks to fluidics and the alignment
calculates the laser delay and lets you
know if any parameter has failed and why
the quality control results are tracked
using Levi Jennings graphs automatically
saved in the quality control module of
the side of Flex you see let's talk
about compensation and how Saito flex
brings innovation even to this
challenging aspect of flow cytometry one
thing which we have to emphasize and
which is an advantage of the Avalanche
photodiodes compared to PMT TSA's that's
the APD's the photo diodes are much more
linear compared to PMT's we do not
adjust the voltages in the side to flex
we just increase the gain and because of
the linearity when you adjust the gain
the software is actually able to
calculate new compensation factors on
the new gain what this allows you to do
is to run one experiment with positive
controls with the dies and store in a
compensation library in the site expert
software if for a different experiment
you change the gain settings in other
words you change the sensitivity of the
photo diodes you do not have to run the
positive controls again to calculate the
new compensation matrix the software is
able to adjust to the new gain settings
and transform the composition matrix
this makes it much easier and saves you
time
in this slide I talked about the
analysis features available with the
site expert software the site experts
software has a fully featured analysis
suite with all the ability to show the
different plot types you would like to
use in analysis including overlays it
has ease-of-use features like dragging
and dropping plots anywhere in the
workspace panning inside a plot zooming
into a population of interest and plots
to show the gating hierarchy and colors
of the repopulation of interest the
fight expert software can be used
offline it requires a computer with
Windows 7 it supports Windows 7 32 and
64-bit it is provided free of charge
with instrument it can also be copied
over a USB Drive and installed on your
personal computer as it does not require
a license or a dongle to be used the
files generated by the site expert
software utilize the FCS 3.0 standard
and you can export the flow cytometry
files from this software which can be
read by other analysis software like
Colusa from Beckman culture FCS Express
and flo-jo
let's talk about the maintenance side of
things the phyto flex is designed to be
simple to use and deliberate in your lab
you have to purchase a limited number of
consumables there is the sheet fluid
like any conventional flow cytometer you
have contract 70 which is used for deep
cleaning you have flow clean which is a
detergent based cleaner to get rid of
proteins left in the tubing and then you
have an easily replaceable sheet filter
which is disposable and designed to be
replaced by the operator himself in five
to ten minutes every six months the
fight expert software eats you in the
maintenance by having pre-built start up
and image initialization cycles it can
back flush automatically between samples
to minimize sample carryover it has
priming functions and it has shutdown
cycles which utilize just threes three
reagents so to summarize the side
effects but platform of which side
flicks s is an extension gives you a
high performance system in a compact
system this performance is enabled due
to the use of the innovative WDM module
with Avalanche photodiodes and the
choice of lasers and fluorescence
detectors allows you to choose the side
effect system which is suitable for your
current research project not to forget
the sight of flex and the side effects s
are a breathable in the field as your
research fields and requirements expand
it comes with software which is fully
featured intuitive and the maintenance
is simple of the system with this I
conclude my presentation and I would be
excited to receive questions
at this stage over to you Robert okay so
very much and thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A march box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we're gonna try to answer as many
questions with time allows our first
question inside of Flex asks be upgraded
to support more colors yes the hyda flex
s has upgrade pathways available you can
have a system which can have blue yellow
violet lasers or you can have a system
which has blue yellow red and near UV
capabilities however we can start with a
side of Lexus system which has six
floors and detectors unlocked and you
can go up to unlocking all the 13
fluorescence detectors when your
application needs to require it and you
have the budget to match the only
limitation in the grid pathway is that
if you have ordered a system which has
four lasers excluding the fifth laser
which can be near UV or yellow or violet
you cannot have the fifth laser which
was excluded in the first place into the
site of flex s system you have so to
conclude it is easy to unlock
fluorescent detectors and the side flex
s but if you already have four lasers
you cannot add the fifth laser later on
I hope this answers the question our
next question is is a site expert
software easy to learn
yes we definitely believe so and the
proof is in the pudding that you can go
to our website and get online training
using on-demand
web-based computer training program
which will also issue you with a
certificate the site expert software we
find as per feedback from field
application specialists can be taught in
one or two sessions thank you thank you
our next question can we expect more
colors and or more lasers in the future
at the moment we have no options of
increasing the number of colors
available on the site flex s platform
however we will be adding a six laser
option for the fido-flex s which will be
in the infrared spectrum to excite dyes
like alexa fluor 780 so pretty soon you
will have the option of choosing four
lasers for side flex as from a choice of
six lasers thank you it supports s CS
3.0 so by default it supports all
versions of s CS files no I'm afraid not
the FCS 2.0 and 2.1 files from the older
generation of flow cytometer z' it's not
supported by the site expert software
Thank You own multiple configurations
available any recommendations on
choosing a starter configuration that
can be upgraded in the future right so
this is an interesting question you have
to decide in the beginning which are the
floor prompts you are going to use if
your work is going to focus more on
using fluorescent proteins then you
should choose the side effects s system
with the yellow laser if you're going to
work with DNA staining
stem cell side populations then you
would go for the near UV laser when it
comes to the other laser choices you
have to choose which is more important
having the blue and red laser
combination for the very common
fluorochromes or having a blue and
violet laser combination the violet
laser is specially useful if you're
going to look at nanoparticles so like I
said as for my answer for a previous
question it is quite possible to upgrade
the capabilities from six to eight to
thirteen colors but you have to choose
the correct four lasers from the start
if you exclude a laser it cannot be
added in the future
thank you the next question
could you give the speed of the sheep
per sampling swirl yes I've loaded up a
slide to show this we have three preset
sample rates slow which will take a tan
microliter per minute medium 30 mark
liter per minute and fast which will
take 16 micro liter per minute however
you also have a custom sample flow rate
slider in which you can go all the way
up to 240 micro liter per minute as for
sheep consumption the saito flex has the
option of putting it on standby mode
when the system is on standby mode it
will not be running sheet fluid through
the flow cell and the fluidics and only
when you need to run a sample you will
initialize the system and consume the
Sheep according to your preset sample
rates I hope this answers the question
thank you
and thank you from Allah and Azam do you
have any final words for the
presentation for today yes I would like
to say that the site of flex platform is
something which Beckman Coulter is very
actively working on we came up with the
original site of flags and globally
released it in 2015
soon after we added the plate loader
option in 2015 from the last quarter we
introduced the side reflects s with the
yellow green laser and this year we have
added the new UV laser option along with
additional band pass filters for the
Euro laser system like I mentioned we
are going to add a six laser option and
we are also listening to the customer
feedback and we will be open to
developing us extended site of flags
which will have more than four lasers at
the same time I hope this answers
question thank you thank you and again
thank you to Allah and Azam for their
outstanding presentation I would also
like to say a special thank you for
Beckman Coulter for making today's
education webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through October of 2017
your receive and email from lab roots
allergens in this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye